I'm losing a pound a week. What could I do to gain weight while avoiding dairy sugar and carbs?
Well, the first question to ask is, are you overweight or underweight? If you're still
feel like you're overweight, then I would say just continue with your diet. If you'd say no,
I'd really like to weigh 165. That's where I feel the best and I'm down to 150 now. And I'm losing
a pound a week and weigh underweight. Then you either need to increase your total overall calories
or you need to increase your complex carbohydrates. The only way that you're going to gain weight
is really to eat complex to eat carbohydrates. If you eat only protein, you will lose weight
because you need carbohydrates in order to gain weight. So if you only ate, you know,
let's say you're not eating 80 carbs whatsoever, the chance you be, you know,
pushing yourself to a state of pakexia or high. So you can't do that. You're going to have to eat
some carbs and I would suggest you add or complex carbs back, some oatmeal, some potatoes,
things like that. You have to make sure you maintain your weight.